hi i'm mike lebruno owner of albright
pressure washing and more we specialize
in gutter cleaning and pressure washing
of homes and businesses in southeast
north carolina
i'm going to show you how we clean
clogged gutters before winter
in the fall we're going to have a lot of
leaves and debris that fall so it's
important to check your gutters before a
snow storm if we have snow that
accumulates on a roof we can have some
water runoff as temperatures rise that
snow will melt causing excessive rain
water to flow into the gutter and freeze
and unfreeze potentially causing water
to expand back up into the interior of
your home underneath the roof line
we start by inspecting gutters by
removing any debris from the roof dry
debris consists of leaves dirt and
shingle grit which can cause excessive
weight inside of the gutter too
pressure washer is a great tool for
cleaning out gutters but if it's too
compacted we will first need to resort
to hand picking this we want to pick out
as many clumps and clogs wet or dry
debris as we can
wet debris is just a little bit muddier
and we have water added with it which is
excessive weight inside of the gutter
stressing it out
if we find a big clog such as wet
compacted debris in some cases we have
to take the downspout apart we will
start at the bottom by removing rivets
or screws to get closer to our clog or
backup
once we're done hand picking all the
debris we can we want to perform our
flush test this is where we will take a
pressure washer and run water in the top
of the gutter towards the downspout for
at least 10 to 20 seconds we want to
remove any remaining debris that we did
not get from hand picking and we want to
see good clear flow of water diverting
away from the home and foundation we
will start at the top of the gutter and
then move to the downspout to ensure we
have no remaining debris and everything
is flowing correctly
if we see clear water and good flow and
hear hollow sound
there are no clogs present if there is a
clog present we want to tap on that
downspout and determine where the clog
is
we want to run water through the top of
the downspout
and have someone at the bottom
checking to make sure that debris is
starting to flow through
here this is all pine straw that's been
collecting for at least a couple years
we are using a tap shake method along
with running water in the top of the
gutter to break up the debris and flush
out all of the pine straw
a good way to tell that your gutters are
flowing properly is there will be no
water running over the top of the gutter
and you will see clear water at the
bottom of the downspout
depending on the type of tree and
location of landscaping around your home
will determine how often you should
clean your gutters out and what type of
debris may fall in them
a good practice would be to trim back
trees as needed and plant future trees
further away from the home